if somebody's watching this and you know
they've heard about it a million times
people are talking about around them
they've read articles seen stuff on tv
if somebody wants to test this out for
the first time ever
how do you suggest one going about doing
intermittent fasting
you have to understand that there's uh
you have to build up to it generally
because you do
have there's a bit of a if you've never
done it there's about a two week period
where you're gonna have to get used to
it because you're gonna get hungry first
of all you have to understand
that it gets easier and easier as you do
it longer
but the other thing is that your body
needs time because if you've never
sort of gone long periods of time then
you're going to get a little bit
you know hungry and angry and all that
sort of stuff right but it's about two
weeks and then it goes away
so there's that period of adaptation so
you can sort of ease into it
so you start by cutting out snacks the
other thing uh and then you go to like
you know a time restricted eating which
is like 16 hours of fasting so you eat
for eight hours of the day and then you
can keep going more you can go to 20
hours or 24 hours of fasting
so you can sort of ease your way into it
or you can just jump in the other thing
that makes it easier
is eating a low carbohydrate diet tends
to make it easier to get into the
fasting
because eating more of the fat and the
protein tends to keep you full for
longer so it's easier to sort of stay
full
for the period of time that you need to
so
and the other thing is just to get the
right information so
that's that's where i wrote the books
and also on the fastingmethod.com i have
i have blogs for you know i think they
go back to like
2013 i had a weekly blog so there's tons
of stuff at that
so the website's the fastingmethod.com
we have a program there also to provide
information and a community and all this
coaching and all that sort of stuff but
there's a lot of free stuff on there too
but you got to get the right information
because you need to know what to expect
so if if for example one of the very
common things is that people get
headaches when they start fasting
so if you know that some people get
headaches
and you know that they'll go away well
then you can deal with it
or constipation for example constipation
is very common because if there's less
going in
there's less going out so it shouldn't
be very uncomfortable but how are you
going to deal with that
you get the flip side too some people
actually get diarrhea when they start so
again what do you do about that
so again the body is actually trying to
dump water and sometimes
it's just dumping so much that you get
this diarrhea but also understanding
that that
you know hey you might get a headache
and then when you get the headache then
then you know that hey i can expect it
and i can expect it to go away
so therefore you know how to handle it
as opposed to just jumping in and saying
oh i got this terrible headache the
first time i did it it was terrible
so i'm never doing it again it's like
well you didn't get the right
information of what to expect
so you weren't able to sort of
successfully go through because the
point
of fasting is that you know diets are
great
but there's an inherent limit to most
diets so if you eat a mediterranean diet
that's great
but if you're not losing the way you
want to lose
you can't get more you can't be more
mediterranean right or more paleo or
whatever if you're eating
low carb it's hard to be more low-carb
if you're vegetarian you can't get more
vegetarian right
there's an inherent limit to that as
opposed to fasting where there's
actually no
limit that is you can fast for 16 hours
you can fast for 16 days
if you want to and the other thing is
that is it is it going to work right
that's the other thing because you don't
want to do a diet to lose weight if it's
not going to work
well there's really nothing that works
any better because you're eating zero
so it's low everything it's low calorie
it's not it's not you know there's no
animal products there's no nuts
it's zero you can't get lower than zero
so as a diet it really is the ultimate
in weight loss
there's no possible way you can do
better
than zero so therefore it will work
so it will work and there's no limit to
how long you can go
so therefore that gives you a huge
advantage because you can you can apply
it
and there's a lot of other advantages
too for fasting which is
uh one of the reasons it's so powerful
that is it
it really talks about the timing
when to eat part of it it doesn't matter
if you're vegetarian or paleo or keto or
whatever
so you can add it to any diet it's
free so it doesn't cost any money
right so if you try to eat a keto diet
and you're you know you're some poor guy
and you know in the inner city and
you're sick well you can make yourself
better for free because it actually
not only doesn't cost money but it
doesn't it actually saves you money you
don't have to buy food
it's convenient because you don't have
to
cook food you don't have to clean up you
don't have to eat i mean
that's a shot you're gonna get all that
time back
it's flexible that is you can do it
anywhere anytime
there's no inherent limitation is it
common for people to do it on wednesdays
from
6 p.m till noon the next day is that the
typical schedule because that's when
most people do it in the office here
it can be any day um you know
there's a lot of different strategies so
that sort of um
sort of time restricted eating which is
just picking a time
is very effective especially you know if
you do it with a group of people so if
everybody in the office is like you know
we're not eating between
this and this that's very effective
because that
is the secret to why people are able to
fast because they did it in groups
right so if you're you know say it's
lent
and you know your priest is talking to
you
about uh you know it's lent and you
should fast
well you're fasting your family is
fasting
your friends are fasting everybody you
know in this community is fasting
well guess what you're gonna do it even
though you don't particularly like it
it's gonna be easy because that's the
easy way to go or ramadan
everybody in your family most of your
friends are fasting because it's ramadan
it you're gonna do it if your office is
doing it together that's fantastic that
is
probably the most important thing is to
have the supportive community
of people who are like we understand the
benefits
and we think that it would be great to
all do this together
and get healthier because what we're
going to do is we're going to lose some
weight
we're going to get our blood sugar down
because when you don't eat
your body is going to burn up that blood
sugar and that's the secret to
type 2 diabetes because if you don't eat
your blood sugar will come down
and you don't need medications anymore
and you're going to get healthier
for it so that that that community that
understanding that's sort of the most
important thing so that that wednesday
from
6 p.m till the next day is perfect now
what what can you do during that time
what can you have
i hear water coffee that's all i hear
yeah so
tea is also a good alternative so in a
classic fast you're talking water only
um but if you're talking for weight loss
there's all kinds of other stuff you
could use that
is fine so tea is great green tea is
good
green tea may actually be a little bit
better than most because it has certain
antioxidants called catechins that
actually help suppress the appetite a
little bit
and you can get all sorts of herbal teas
flavored teas i worked with a company
called peak tea to make these fasting
teas that have
all these sort of antioxidants and stuff
coffee is great but just avoid
the sweeteners and the sugars
[Music]